Speaker 1: Well, ladies and gentlemen, let the
insanity begin. Donald Trump's tax returns have
been released and now we are all going to be
poring over them like the wannabe accountants
that we all are. When COVID hit, we all became
epidemiologists on Twitter, and now we will
all be tax accountants and tax attorneys, of
course. Now, I'm exaggerating a little bit,
but much anticipated. I mean, listen, it took
years to get these things, so we're sure as hell
going to be taking advantage of looking at these.
The New York Times reporting Trump Tax Returns
Released by House Democrats. The publication of
former President Trump's private tax documents
come amid questions about why did the IRS fail to
fully audit him during his presidency. Despite his
claims, which we call lies I call untrue claims
lies, particularly when you know they're untrue,
that he was under audit. I encourage you to check
out the entire New York Times article as we speak.
The documents are being analyzed now. There is
a good CBS News piece about what is it that tax
professionals are looking for? What do the returns
actually show about? His finances is one question.
And this comes to how wealthy is he? What assets
does he have? What asset values does he claim?
Is there evidence of tax fraud and all of the
other things that we have been talking about?
What do the tax returns show about the amount of
tax that he pays? That piece we had a report on
from the House Ways and Means Committee based
on the underlying documents. Now we're getting
the underlying documents. We know he paid very,
very little in taxes, claimed losses, some years
paid zero, some years, got a refund some years. So
that's going to be a big area of focus. How much
money has Trump actually made, including from
being famous? That's a question that will
potentially be answered by the tax returns. How
charitable is Donald Trump and then some of these?
I don't think these are really the questions
like how lucrative is it to be a real estate
developer? It's more like how sketchy are Trump's
sources of financing? I think that those are far,
far, far more interesting questions. CNN has an
early report on what is in there. And, of course,
the the one piece we learned right away, Donald
Trump pays very little in federal taxes despite
the fact that we know that he continued to enrich
himself while he was president of the United
States. CNN writing. The returns long shrouded in
secrecy were released today by the House Ways and
Means Committee. They confirm a report from the
Joint Committee on Taxation that Trump claimed
large losses before and throughout his presidency
that he carried forward to reduce or partially
eliminate his tax burden. For example, in 2015, he
carried forward a $105 million loss, and in 2016,
a $73 million loss. CNN is reviewing the thousands
of pages of these tax returns. I think by early
next week, of course, if not later today, we are
going to have far more detailed information about
what is in these tax returns. Also interesting,
this paragraph here, included with the committee's
report was an analysis of the numbers from each of
the six Trump tax returns by the nonpartisan Joint
Committee on Taxation. Remember, they found that
Trump paid $750 in tax in 2017, nothing in 2020,
and a combined 1.1 million in federal income
taxes in 2018 and 2019. Trump regularly claimed
huge operating losses, which you are allowed
to carry forward. So the big takeaways, the
big questions in no particular order. What will we
learn from the tax returns about Trump's wealth,
about Trump's debts, about Trump's possible
tax fraud? Question number one. Question
number two Is Trump nearly as wealthy as he
claims to be? I think we know the answer is
no. What sorts of sketchy lending and debt
sources does Donald Trump have that may have
even been a conflict of interest while he
was president of the United States? Will
this play a role in the subsequent possible
indictments coming against Donald Trump? And
will anybody who would even consider voting for
Donald Trump in 2024 even care about what's in
there? I believe Trump was correct when he
said he could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
and not lose support. If he could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and not lose support,
is he going to lose support because of some late
tax fraud or because he lied about his wealth?
I don't think so. And so it's been a long fought
battle. It's a matter of principle, I believe,
at this point where every other president has
released their tax returns other than Donald
Trump. But will this actually have consequences?
I find it. Really, really difficult to believe
that it will. The next question is, does
it even matter if Trump is destined to
fail as the potential Republican presidential
nominee? That's what I want to talk about next.